About every two seconds, someone in the United
States needs blood.
That is a lot of blood to transfuse from donors
to patients.
But how on Earth did we develop the procedure?
Hey guys, Amy with you on DNews today.
Now, the faults and failures of early transfusions
have significantly helped shape how blood
transfusion procedures work today.
Long before anyone really understood blood,
scientists knew that blood was a life force
flowing through us all.
To harness the power of blood and infuse it
into another person, usually someone sick
or dying, patients would usually drink the
blood which of course had no effect.
The idea of a blood transfusion didn’t actually
occur until William Harvey’s 1628 discovery
that blood circulates through the body in
one direction.
It was then, that scholars and doctors realized
that transfusions were a possible method of
rejuvenating the sick
By the end of the 17th century, physicians
were using quills as needles and silver pipes
to transfer blood from a donor to a recipient,
but the donor was usually an animal.
But what no one knew at the time was animal
blood cells are incompatible with human blood.
It wasn’t until obstetrician James Blundell
started using human blood to replace blood
lost in childbirth in the early 1800s, that
transfusions started working, at least some
of the time.
Physician Karl Landsteiner set out to figure
out why some blood transfusion patients lived
and others died, a line of inquiry that led
him to discover the ABO blood type groups
in 1901.
It was Landsteiner’s groundbreaking work
that helped classify blood into one of four
categories: A, B, AB, and O.
These are defined by the antigens and antibodies
on the cells.
People with type A blood, for example, have
the A antigen on the surface of their red
cells and their bodies won’t produce the
anti-A antibodies.
So if any type A blood is introduced into
that person’s body, it won’t recognize
the new cells as foreign and won’t attack
them.
But if type B blood is injected into a type
A blood person, the anti-B antibodies on the
donated blood will be seen as foreign.
The host’s body will reject the transfusion.
Another factor for rejection comes down to
a protein on the surface of red blood cells
called the Rhesus or Rh factor.
Blood cells either possess the protein - meaning
that you are Rh positive or not, meaning you
are negative.
These factors combine to make eight blood
types.
Now all of this is important because your
blood type determines your compatibility with
a donor.
The red blood cells of people with type O
blood have A or B antigens on their surface,
making them a universal donor.
People with type AB blood don't produce any
antibodies so they are universal recipients.
But everyone else is only compatible with
their specific type.
So knowing what we’ve learned over centuries
of trial and error, blood transfusions have
become simpler.
There’s no need for a living donor.
Instead, donated red blood cells can be stored
for as long as 42 days, meaning a patient
in need is simply given an IV and a bag of
blood to replenish what they’re missing
or restore blood lost
in an accident.